pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieuse et les épis curieux
j'espère que vous allez bien que vous à
passer de bonnes fêtes nous sommes
mercredi et je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour répondre à vos questions
[Musique]
pitau auriol sur youtube déjà mis dans
ton livre tu dis que thomas pesquet
repartira pour l' iss c'est pour quand
exactement
alors je ne suis pas dans les petits
papiers de la nasa mais normalement
thomas pesquet devrait repartir au
printemps 2021 j'ai entendu parler du 31
mars ce sera le deuxième séjour de
thomas pesquet à bord de la station
spatiale internationale la première fois
il s'y est rendu à bord de la fusée
soyouz
une fusée russe cette fois il voyagera à
bord du vaisseau roux dragonne qui sera
emporté par une fusée falcon 9
développé par la société d'elon musk
space x
évidemment je vais suivre cette
expédition de très très près et j'aurais
sûrement l'occasion de vous en reparler
dit jamie à caen pons l'année avec pause
fleurs alors j'ai rencontré pons fleurs
lors d'une émission pop corn avec
domingo et je serai ravi de retrouver et
pons flanc je suis persuadé qu'il a
plein de choses à m'apprendre et à
m'expliquer sur les jeux vidéo donc
voilà pons jaton l'habitation une
question de louis sur instagram dit
jamie pourquoi le surnom jamie et bien
je suis désolé oui mais janice n'est pas
un surnom c'est mon vrai prénom c'est
celui qu'ont choisi mes parents et qui
figure sur mon état civil et surtout mes
papiers et oui je m'appelle j'ai mis
magenta sur youtube déjà née à turin
conseils pour bien travailler et
apprendre à l'école alors si j'ai un
conseil à donner c'est celui d'apprendre
à se concentrer dans les encours soyez
concentrer sur ce que guy vote
enseignant es obligé vous à vous
concentrer
la deuxième chose n'apprenez pas
comprenez et une fois que vous avez
compris
là vous apprendrez beaucoup plus
facilement c'est exactement ce que je
fais quand je prépare une émission je
commence par reprendre
et après j'apprends et vous verrez ça
passe cren diar cette expression j'ai
apprise il n'ya pas longtemps
en même temps c'était facile à
comprendre dit jamie tu sais comment on
appelle les gens qui collectionnent les
plaques de bouchons champagne oui je
sais ce sont les plaques au museau fils
alors placo dans la plaque museau pour
le museler et fils et bien parce que
quand on est collectionneur
on aime l'objet qu'on collectionne placo
mais au fil l'oregon où loge aux gones
sur youtube déjà ni combien pèses les
nuages bien tout dépend de la densité de
l'eau qu'il contient cette eau peut se
présenter soit l'état gazeux et liquides
ou solides
ensuite il y a la surface occupée par le
nuage quelques dizaines de mètres pour
un cumulus plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres pour un foyers orageux
ensuite il y à la hauteur du nuage
certains cumulonimbus peuvent s'étirer
sur 15km de hauteur
bref si le brouillard pèse quelques kg
par mètre cube un cumulonimbus peut
contenir entre 50000 tonnes et 300 mille
tonnes d'eau les plus importants jusqu'à
800 mille tonnes d'eau ça pas la douche
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche